we're at the historic paramount lot
right here in hollywood and all week
long we're kicking off today's show with
a very special performance featuring
dancers from hollywood california adele
carrera founded the non-profit dance
engagements as a way to empower dance
enthusiasts of all ages shapes and sizes
i love them and they're here
take it away
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
yes i am so honored that you're here
today and i want to share something with
you
i um my mom was one of those moms who
put me in like tat jazz ballet um and i
really did not feel like i fit in
anywhere then there was a dance troupe
but funny enough
they
the teacher was really tough on all the
girls
um who weren't tall and skinny i'm just
going to say it out loud and i felt like
an outcast and i didn't feel good about
myself
and until my mom took me to karate
found something and that might have been
seeds for something like a charlie's
angels
because i felt good about the way that i
was made and who i was and i found my
people so i want to ask you
adele
what
made you change the system and help
people not feel like i did when i was a
kid right
well i think dance is a very
intimidating community yes so it is
important to display for our mission
that all ages shapes and sizes are
capable of dancing and everyone should
have
[Music]
and anyone should have access to dance
um i'm watching you guys and every
single one of you has got the moves
you are so
money
um
who inspires you as a dancer may i ask
growing up definitely my biggest
inspiration definitely hands down missy
elliott
she
was someone
who
she was not she did not have backup
dancers she was a dancer she engaged she
fully did choreo and it made gave me
that inspiration of like i can do that
too yeah she is such an inspiration
she really is um well missy elliott
actually heard about what you've been
doing and she has a special message for
you
hey adele it is missy miss demina
elliott and i just want to say first of
all congratulations i love what you are
doing with dance engagements and all the
dances and i know it's gonna continue to
grow big and i can't wait i'm gonna be
right here cheering you on and i heard
that i inspire you but guess what you
inspire me and i want you to continue to
do what you're doing is amazing i
love you
it looks like you might inspire someone
that inspired you
how great does that feel
that's wild
um i just want to thank you guys for
coming today i'd also want uh to donate
ten thousand dollars to
your um
amazing school
from me
and let this be the beginning of a
beautiful friendship support go to the
drewberrymoreshow.com to learn more
about adele's program and
thank you to the choreographing duo
tyrell and latrina
who have choreographer artists you know
um they've choreographed for some uh
people called beyonce
and justin timberlake and mariah carey
so uh thank you you guys so much
so
much
thank you
thank you thank you thank you
[Music]